hello everyone and welcome to the oven
carmichael show-- i am your host Evan
Carmichael I believe that hungry
entrepreneurs deserve help so today I'm
talking to you about your business I've
got a really exciting show lined up
today but first I need to warn you I was
a really late last night I was hosting a
dance party with one of the companies
that I'm an investor in and so today I'm
running on fumes but I went to my local
coffee shop I picked up a nice
cappuccino that I'm drinking throughout
the show so I'm excited because there's
a lot of great content that I want to
get through here's what I'm talking
about today I'm talking with habit be
opportunistic how to get more referrals
how to make money on fiverr.com and I
have a special guest mark Mason is
joining me who has bought a house from
the money he made on fiber and how to
make a million dollars answering that
million-dollar question it is important
that your opportunistic with your
business you have to chase down the
opportunities ahead of you otherwise
you're going to end up living a life
full of regret that you never took your
shot my family likes to call me an
aggressive driver and I prefer the word
opportunistic now I'll be careful
because I know my mom is into the show
hi mom I just say still work today I'm
not going to be the guy who's tailgating
you who is flashing his lights at you
who's talking is horn at you I'm not
that driver but if I see a chance to get
ahead but cut into the next Lane then
you can bet your bottom dollar that I am
going to take it and you need the same
approach with your business you have to
be opportunistic you have to chase down
those opportunities there's two major
problems with a lot of entrepreneurs the
first are the one of the entrepreneurs
these are the guys who have a great idea
but they're stuck in a corporate job and
they're too afraid to take their shot
here's what's going to happen you're
going to watch somebody else make big
dollars off of your idea while you wish
that you went for it when you're older
and you look back on your life you're
not going to say to yourself I wish I
took fewer chances if you have a great
idea it is a great opportunity in front
of you you have to go for it you've got
to do something today and start taking
action you can't be afraid the second
kind of entrepreneur are the ones who
are running their business you're doing
your business you're taking your shot
you're trying to make it work but you're
so busy doing the day-to-day work doing
the paperwork putting out fires handling
all the crap that you have to do in your
business they're so buried in your
company that you're missing out on the
big opportunity to take your company
forward every time I've had a growth in
my business a major leap forward is
because I took off the things on my
plate that were tying up my time you
have to make room for what I call CEO
time you need to have that built into
your day to help you focus on your
growth think about when you get the best
ideas for your company when'd you get
your best ideas are they when you're
stressed out overworked coming home and
having barely any time to sleep not
eating well not taking care of yourself
is that when you get your best ideas or
is it when you're relaxed when you go on
vacation when you're having a shower
when you're playing sports or taking a
walk you have to make sure you free up
your time you have an opportunity to
grow and I know what you're thinking hey
I'm busy writing the business is hard
work I don't have time to do that
nobody's going to get the stuff done if
I don't do it and you know what you're
right I know right in business is hard
one of the hardest things you ever going
to do in your life but here's the
problem here's the truth
if you don't make time for that CEO time
if you don't put the hours in to focus
on the growth of your business you are
constantly going to be running on that
treadmill running running running trying
to get further ahead and not moving
anywhere you're going to hit a plateau
and you're not going to know how to bust
through it and you're going to start to
hate your fit your business hate your
life you need to make sure you plan that
CEO time into your day into your weeks
into your month and that you're relaxed
and not to stress that an overworked so
that when an opportunity comes to you
you have the capacity to jump on it
you're not just doing the same thing
over and over and over again and not
seen any growth with your business let's
get to the calls we have the key key on
the line Kiki where are you from and how
can I help I'm from Memphis Tennessee
welcome to the program what's going on
um I actually have an idea i mean i live
like in a woman i try and say i actually
wanted to open up like a laundry mat
okay and just didn't know how to go
about trying to do that whether i should
explore business loan or try to find a
grant that would support support me why
do you want to go under um I just feel
like it would probably be you know
easier to run I'm thinking and I know
that's okay you know what you're at the
very early stages of running the
business and and it's great to explore
your options the thing is if you want to
have a lot of success as an entrepreneur
you have to build a business around
something that you passionately believe
it right that you love doing so maybe
you love laundry hey I'm not judging but
yeah it doesn't sound like that's
something that really you know pulls at
your heartstrings right yeah this is
just trying to make money
but usually not going to is there
something else that you can do something
a passion you're really excited about
that maybe you could turn into a
business fashion I like the designing
designing okay have you say anything
have you helped people with their
designing their clothes or designing
what do you just have no I think about
getting a certain software that you know
kind of helps you design you know close
something about starting starting there
okay then maybe no making some pieces
and wearing them and showcase win like
that that's a great start you know
anybody who needs some clothes as well
but you might be able to help them out
with yes a lot of people why are you
laughing yeah yeah I was just getting
it's a lot of people that need help for
instance could you would enjoy doing yes
I live close a love designing a little
back being and you know love it so why
would you pick a laundry mat over over
this i'm just looking at it it's the way
for me to get started the bid on
something that i really want to do right
so my suggestion would be to start right
in with something that you're passionate
about does the laundromat is still going
to be a ton of work yeah you work that
you don't enjoy doing right and if you
started the business around something
you're excited about like fashion you
make your own clothes it's going to be
fun you can help people out who have
fashion issues as well well yeah and
you'll have fun like when you're helping
people you have fine that gives you
energy but it can also make you a lot of
money right what's my next step what's
your next step to making that dream
happen oh well like I said just
showcasing it you know bout me by
wearing it and people saying oh I like
that isn't you know and I like a word of
mouth thing and
maybe giving it you know personally
getting into some or maybe what can you
meet this week to get started on it
actually works it start with a design
and try to put together some actually
throwing a couple not a couple pieces
buzz a piece okay are you gonna do it
yes are you excited yes I am yes all
right good hey listen I'm here every two
weeks call back and let me know how
you're progressing a lot because I want
to see this business tick off for you ok
ok I will do this all right thank you so
much Kiki good luck thanks thanks man me
on all right so for all of you listening
you know I know what you're thinking you
want to make money you want to jump in
on something that can make you some
short-term cash but those things really
work out you're going to get frustrated
you're going to lose your money you're
going to hate your business in your life
you have to find and build a business
around something that you are intensely
passionate about brings you joy and you
know is going to help a lot of people
start with that even if it's part time
universe just getting started doesn't
have to be full-time hours do something
that you love you'll feel the energy
from doing it when you're helping people
you're going to love it you're going to
start making money and you can fuel that
success to help you keep going if you
want to grow your business you need to
get referrals preferred customers buy
more from you are more loyal they refer
new business to you you have to build
your business around it small business
doesn't have referrals is dead in the
water and the way to go out and do it is
to support your network don't wait sit
in your chair for business to come to
you you got to go out there stay top of
mind make sure people remember you and
will pass your name on recently a
newsletter person for my newsletter
wrote in and said Evan I need help with
my social media strategy need someone to
help me train on it and I wrote back to
say hey you know what I have a worksheet
I can help you with seven dollars tons
of value but it's a worksheet you know
i'm not i'm not going to do one on one
that's not my business but I have a
and who does that name is Shawn Moffitt
he is a he's also a host on this radio
station and so I called up Shawn and I
made a video doing this but I started
filling my video I Mike myself up I
called up Shawn the answer at this
channel cake first before we get started
you are on camera I'm filming you so
don't say anything you're going to
regret you guys can watch this video up
on youtube today and I told about this
opportunity and he said it was great
thank you so much and I gave him the
chance to also talk about his business
so what's happening here the woman who
wrote in to me is getting help I'm not
getting paid from it but I'm helping her
out John was in my network I'm giving
him a lead and I'm also giving them
exposure on the radio show today now
talking about the story on my youtube
channel and on my website and the people
who are watching the video also get the
benefit as well I'm sending out massive
karma and it's going to come back to
help me I'm not a huge fan of going up
to people and saying hey can you were
first somebody to me because it puts
them on the spot makes them feel awkward
but if you find ways to stay top of mind
support your network you're going to get
referrals coming to you and I know what
you're thinking this is hard you know I
don't have the time to do this I'm
running my business that takes a lot of
time you know what it does it's true but
I guarantee you you're doing things on
your sales in the marketing side that
are not working and this is something
that works this is critical to your
business you have to do it and it's also
fun when you're reaching out to your
network and you're helping them you're
not only going to give them business and
they're going to give you business back
you're going to get new ideas and
opportunities come to you by staying
connected people are busy you have to
stay top of mind but don't sit back and
wait for things to happen go out and
proactively find ways support the people
in your network if in business give them
testimonials give them ideas stay in
touch help them out and they'll help you
out I have i J on the line i J what is
going on where are you from
how can I help okay I'm so west palm
beach florida I have a business making a
big week for consultation and I'm a
quick for people fashion oh is it last I
spoke to you guys about the market in my
business okay last month I did you what
you do you make wheat yeah week week for
the constipation Kimbra have a very
erotic okay perfect and you're trying to
figure how to market your business yes I
spoke single guys a month a month all on
the 14 or 15 between that serious I
supposed to you that you guys told me
how to market my business as you go
today cancer hospital so I went there
and market my business since then I
spoke to you guys the encouragement you
guys evening I business yes your is
nothing to be massaged but that's crazy
she got some advice who are you
partnering up with because there's
nobody nobody so jeopardize my man yeah
oh come haha so I went to Korea to learn
how to make a week okay so yeah so when
I came back my my husband opener with
shop for me so I thought that designing
me okay so it was so small I don't know
how to market it but let that you had
your own store yes okay and the people
who are coming in are typically what
kind of client read where people know
people that I really wanted people who
doesn't you know they just came a look
and they go back what girls almost are
they facing because it usually takes
problem p the money they can afford to
buy the week because they expensive okay
yeah that's the problem so I don't know
how to get the as a chalk line but they
will know that this is you know a good
meat shop how do you promote your shop
what's your sales pitch my percentage
yeah what's your sales pitch fly in the
day I can make a thousand two thousand
depends how the people coming no I mean
how do you sell it so if I was comin at
ya 300 upwards is 200 of course
not asking about the price I warned you
that I want you to tell me so I'm a
customer walking in I'm a semi older guy
i'm balding I'm thinking about a wig
what are you going to tell me why are
you so great why should I spend money
with you oh you're welcome I said
welcome this is a good week I bring out
the week as it is a human hair hundred
percent human hair natura oh yeah there
then you ask me a question wanna know
you gotta you gotta you gotta sell me
like a lot of people have natural human
hair wigs right that's not
differentiating you from other people
well yeah I can look over your wigs that
nobody else does because it's different
i go to your staff and i make sure your
hair your hair follicle all the problem
you have whether you want to put it I
put it to you and I finally for you a
cottage I color it I do everything but
overload okay no nobody has do that
except you went to alone do it mother
this is what you need to use in your
pitch the problem may not be the people
don't have the money they may not know
fully what you're what you're offering
your people don't understand why they
need to buy weight from you versus
everybody else they need to know what
makes you different than being human
hair it's not enough so in your pitch
you have to talk about all the things
that make you different and special and
unique and what I need to buy from you
over everybody else yes I did it that I
make it that right away for you you just
be the way i show you how did we get
made I still do everything are you you
know and I started so that have to be
built into your pitch when you're
talking to people when they say hi I'm
it's been in a wig that all has to come
out so just a human hair it's not enough
right you have to say why you're
different because they're probably not
just going to go to you they're going to
go to other wig stores to we care so
yeah I'm gonna win that business and
it's going to be from vain this is a
quality product we have a unique process
that helps you and you explain it the
only way to get this done this is the
only one doing it in America yeah to go
to Asia otherwise to get it done okay
that's good friend right
yes be right down yeah that's a very
good idea yes you're right ok good luck
hey I'm on every two weeks if you want
to call back with another question let
me know how you're doing I'll be here ok
all right thank you very much oh I like
that thank you thank you for calling me
take care bye so for everybody was it
some industry hey when people say what
do you do it's got to make sense you
gotta have something that makes it easy
for people to learn about your business
but also share it fiverr.com fi ve RR
com is a website that I signed up for
about a year ago and where people buy
and sell both these services for five
dollars at a time I've been a little bit
on the side of Barden filled a little
bit and they came across one of the
fiber members his name is a narco
fighter on fire or his real name is mark
mason and i discovered the heat bought a
house from the proceeds he made as a
seller on Fiverr and so I've invited him
to join as a guest today to talk about
his success and introduce it to you guys
mark how are you doing I'm doing often
the love of Evan Carmichael so good to
be here and help the entrepreneurial
listeners really make a transformation
in their business that will make a huge
difference that's awesome welcome to the
program now or my audience who many of
them have no idea what fiber is could
just give a quick intro sure absolutely
the best way to understand fibers to
realize it's like other experiences that
they will instantly understand as soon
as I just say the URL because it's a
marketplace it's sort of taking the what
I like to call the worldwide wild west
of the internet and changing it a little
bit and making it a place where buyers
and sellers think can congregate and do
so in a much more orderly fashion you
know there's been a little the
pioneering is over and the settlers have
started them the example I would use is
like eBay we understand when you go to
ebay that there's going to be and at
ebay primarily things right mr.
Carmichael there's things that eBay that
are for sale and there are vendors
selling it and as we've watched the
transformation of ebay from the day when
it was first
use lipstick containers to what it is
today there are stores that are complete
enterprises taking place in that
marketplace well Ivor is essentially
like being able to be a part of
something like eBay at this point now
when it was just three years old because
that's what I risk and three and I think
April or so my March or April and so so
it's a young marketplace but it has
taken and tamed the world wild web if
you will and made it so that we as
entrepreneurs who just want to be about
transacting our services not about
becoming experts and internet marketing
to do so effectively okay so mark a lot
of my listeners are going to be thinking
you know what I'm so busy running my
company I can barely keep up on my
website and my blog and social media why
should they care why should they log in
the fiber and open the account why
should they care about this well you
nail the right question the first thing
to do without a doubt is to open an
account and here's the number one reason
why because one of the very best ways to
expand your business perhaps even to get
out of that sense of a rat race of doing
all of these tasks that you know are
important are occasionally even urgent
but often are quite consuming of your
time one of the very first things to do
on fibre is to open an account and then
become a buyer become a shopper learn
the lay of the land since this is
somebody else's marketplace and we're
sort of going into their home learn what
it looks like learn how it worked and my
suggestion would be to go ahead and buy
back some of your time by taking some of
those activities maybe you hire somebody
to write a blog post for you maybe you
hire somebody to go get some additional
links or light or or friends on your
social networking site or maybe simply
to go ahead and feed follow up with
birthday messages when they pop up on
skype so the first thing to do is to buy
back that time so that there's more time
to do the things in your business but
you're not only important and essential
but Frank
lead to to revenue right no okay so how
do you go from making five dollars a
sale to buying a house how does that
happen for you well the reason that it
happens is because five dollars is the
starting point it's not the ending point
take fiber in it self describes as the
largest market place for services
starting at five dollars so by simply
participating in the marketplace you're
rewarded for your performance once
you've had an account that is at least
30 days old and you've made unsuccessful
fails then you're ranked a level one
seller and at that point you're no
longer limited to a nearly five dollar
awesome it can now be as much as forty
five dollar offer well as you may cash
to mr. Carmichael I am at the highest
rank that fiber offers you can't even
just earn this one it its honorary you
have to you have to be awarded it it's
called the top rated seller there is a
level in between called level to which
you can earn nearly by performance it's
automatic it will happen as long as
you're a good spy verse it''s ins and
and so at least fifty completed orders
in am 60-day period of time but at the
top rated cellular level I am able to
turn five dollar sales in the five
hundred dollar sale and as you can
imagine with making you know several
sales a day many of which move right
through what i call my spider funnel and
that really is if i could say the ABC of
fiber for me the ABC of fiber is a
account make your account e fire become
a buyer learn the lay of the land i
vacuumed extra time for yourself and
then finally see craft an offer and
you're going to craft an offer initially
just to get those levels happening and
then as you level up you're going to
recraft your offer and create your file
fiber funnel the method by which you
take five dollar sales in the fifty
dollar sales and ultimately in the
five-hundred-dollar salt got it so as
you get more experience
aronson you move up you can upsell your
customers along the way what do you sell
what's your best selling product right
now or service sure my best sewing my
best selling product or service is on
interestingly how to get publicity how
do I would be having what's happening
right now between you and I think that
is my number one selling gig has
thousands of fans so you know many units
a day and have a complete fiber funnel
built into it so walk with you what that
looks like what do i get for five bucks
fifty barks 500 bucks for you absolutely
and and let me say you know this is my
approach to fiber so I want to own that
there are other approaches that people
take and they're also successful
businesses works for me because I have
an information marketing background so
for five dollars and this is this is I
think important to point out because
you're entrepreneurs may also be saying
look I'm not so sure mark I'm not so
sure Evan but there's anything I'd be
willing to do for just five dollars
right and so for me the thing I'm
willing to do put in close is to have a
file be uploaded just what if delivered
in is on that is automated a fashion as
possible and so for five dollars
somebody gets the media insiders secret
report if they visit vibrant /and our co
fiber they can actually see this offer
it's one of the featured offers fiber
has has picked it for special
recognition and if they were to order
that for five dollars they would find
out what I learned as P in the media
world as a journalist about how people
can it's surefire access to getting
publicity rather than being like these
three out of four people who never get
the publicity even if they try so so if
it's a psychological and historical
opening and understanding on how to get
free publicity to your business now
right off the bat when somebody makes
that purchase decision they're given an
option to order custom ideas for their
business
that has a higher punched at in addition
to that they're offered a list of media
contacts that has a twenty dollar price
tag and their offers the ability to have
a secret system to get on national
television in the LA market if they fit
certain conditions in criterias of the
type of business they have cute yes a
very best part of them is that you out
of every five sales that take place of
those ideas then somebody finds a media
release professional written media
release from me and now we're talking a
few hundred dollars that's great hey
mark this is tons of information thank
you so much if people want to learn more
about you and maybe even order that
service it sounds great where can they
go this is go to fiverr.com /and are so
fighter that's a n AR co fi ght ER and
see all of the offerings there perfect
thank you so much market if i have more
questions about have you home as a
repeat guests love that he is alright
appreciate it what I really love about
50 for those you guys listen is it
basically does the marketing for you
right one of the hardest part about
running a business is getting customers
getting lead and so fiber gives you the
option to be able to get new leads to
your business drive new traffic and then
you can upsell them on all the different
things that you have to offer and as you
heard you can go all the way up to five
hundred dollars on a sale and unmarked
bought a house summit so there's a lot
of opportunity to think I'm going to
have to log back into my account and see
what helps i can do on fibers the
document inspirational talk and i really
appreciate that more coming on if you
guys like them let me know and that
means we'll have num him on as a repeat
guests how do you make a million dollars
that's a million-dollar question one of
my youtube viewers guy asked me evan i
want to make a million dollars in 20
years i have twenty thousand dollars in
savings and let's assume I have no
education I have education system i
don't i made a bitty replies that guy
listen why do you have to wait 20 years
you could do this so much faster the key
and the for you guys loyal listeners
you know my message you have to start a
business around your passion and
something that helps people you want to
make money you have to help people you
want to make lots of money you got to
help people a lot and do something that
you love to do I think back to the first
call to show we had Kiki you talked
about her laundry mat that's not the
million-dollar idea she doesn't love
that business she's moving on to
designing fashion designing clothes
that's what she loves there's an
opportunity there if you are starting a
business you have to do it around
something that you love doing and
something that helps a lot of people
after the other things it doesn't matter
how much money you're throwing up with I
don't care if you have 20,000 the bank's
dear when the bank a hundred thousand
the bank it doesn't matter you don't
need money to make money you need hustle
you need drive you need passion you need
customers you have to listen to them got
to get out there it's never about how
many resources you have its how
resourceful you are an education for
most businesses doesn't matter nobody
asked me what my education is I have an
undergrad a bachelor's degree from the
University of Toronto commerce and
finance and nobody asked me that when
you call in and ask me questions your
business do you stay listen I want to
know what your education is before you
answer my question in most businesses it
doesn't matter now if you're a doctor I
probably don't want to go to a doctor
who didn't graduate high school okay but
otherwise it doesn't really matter and I
know a lot of entrepreneurs who feel
like their lack of an education and
their lack of startup capital hold them
back and as long as you tell yourself
that story it will hold you back it's
just in your head if you look at the
most successful most famous entrepreneur
in the world both of them started with
nothing no money some had an education
but it doesn't matter don't let those
things hold you back you have to build a
business around your passion I want to
get to the calls we got time for one
more caller I have Chantel on the line
Chantel where are you from how can I
help I live in Texas two years now I'm a
finger looking to open up a lot of
businesses with no money my music is
going great at home but the only thing
is I mean
in Texas I want to do a non-profit
business and I'm finding it hard and I
want to know how can I get that going
with no money and Keith IRS away from
you so much okay hold on hold on hold on
what is the main business you want to
start that your singing is that the
nonprofit is it something else what's
the main focus here because of my father
he's a minister I'm gonna roll right now
with the nonprofit okay what did you do
I'm looking to go to young girls and
women who are abused in every way
possible who have children single
strokes single and struggling like
myself with my daughter and I chose
nonprofit because it's a music ministry
and that fits in with my singing my
daughter is a model and a dancer so what
is what do you do that's for your help
what do you actually do for them um well
I want to have change they live far as
getting resources for them to bring them
to church for a better life they help
them with education it whatever resource
I can find for them they get there on
the street see them off the streets get
him in a house getting protected you
know like that give back to the
community farms music um new things for
you yes very new okay so this is great i
love the cars I feel like it ties into
something you're really passionate about
so it's our them a lot you may have your
focus issues yes let's leave that one
alone for now um so when you're out and
trying to promote this and you're trying
to get partners and you're trying to get
support you have to be really clear in
your pitch and what it is that you're
offering right so it's you don't want to
go out and say hey I'm trying to get
everything I can to help these people
you want to have a really clear program
that people can get behind ok so what
how do I voice you guys who excuse it I
don't know I don't want to hit the
airwaves the wrong way but who are the
horny toads and I can get the money but
I have to do some weird favor for it
I'll avoid that so I just I lose my
opportunity but i'm not going to turn
over a pillow for the opportunity
you know what if you're taking money you
have to feel right about it you don't
want to just take money for money and it
comes with all these you no strings
attached exact rate you got to feel
right about the money you're taking so
people are joining your organization if
their sponsors donors mentors I don't
know like there's got to be lots of
people you need to get this thing to go
you have to do your screening okay right
the companies that are getting involved
that the mentor is getting involved they
have to be in it for the right reason
that's right how do i go to them what's
right how do i go through them responses
well search with a pitch like what do
you do to get one in your day using on a
recording artist no I know that you're
recording artists but what is your
organization do but you came in and said
well we try to provide as much resources
as fossil fishes women yes you need to
have a clear program how many people
people have you know they're committed
all over the place their money and time
are going to lots of different places so
to stand out to make them say hey I want
to work with chantal then you got to
convince them you need to have a
passionate plea say why he serves as
business and what you're going to offer
therapy they're clear program like what
are you doing why and how is it going to
help these girls and it doesn't have to
be far-ranging right if it's sometimes
if it's too big you get lost and people
can't wrap their head around it they
might just be connecting you know abuse
women with mentors to help guide them
through the struggling process they
faced with their daily life maybe that's
exactly what it is all right we just got
your pitch thank you use those
assistance what I think that's there for
of another aspect if it's giving them
homes or if it's just bringing them to
the church and making them feel part of
the community whatever it is I pick one
thing to start with make it crystal
clear and get people to understand what
it is that you do okay okay we got some
homework I do let me get started ASAP so
i know you know any player I'm on I'm on
every two weeks if you want to call back
and we'll work through your pitch and
you can you can rock the rooster than a
rich
me know okay also my sure will okay
thanks Chantelle with I fear our
goodbyes so for everybody listening it's
the same issue we're dealing earlier you
know you got to have a clear pitch and
we're talking to our wig friends you got
to know what you're selling how you send
out if you want people to be able talk
about you and understand it hey that's
it we're done for the days time flies
it's crazy thank you so much you can
follow me on Twitter Evan Carmichael
check out the website over Karma com I
want to thank my producers zack and
coordinate you guys rocked it as usual I
will see you guys all in two weeks hey
stay tuned has a great couple weeks to
lock eyes marketing